[Music]
and this is one of my favorites a
comforting smoky bacon sweet corn and
potato soup
thrifty for me is about ingredients that
are in the cupboard
smoky bacon
onions potatoes sweet corn
it's amazing how cheap the ingredients
are they go into this
get your bacon and just cut into nice
chunks i want these nice bite-sized
pieces smoky chunky and just
absolutely delicious it's almost like an
american corn chowder
potatoes give it starch thickness
sweet corn gives it that glossy
delicious flavor
a couple of baileys they're always
hanging around if they're not in your
cupboard they're on someone's drive so
ask to borrow them
they are so powerful and it goes
brilliantly well with the onions and the
bacon
bay leaves in
a couple of potatoes
it's incredible how far you can stretch
something out especially when you bulk
it with potatoes slice them
and dice them
nice and chunky
soups are a fantastic way to use up
leftover veg or meat that might
otherwise go to waste and if you make it
in bulk freeze it in individual portions
and save on lunches throughout the week
so you can see already how hearty and
robust the soup is it's a delicious
combination
onions bacon potatoes
and now
some fresh leeks
open up the leak into four
give that
a nice wash
licks often have soil left in their tops
so it's important to clean them
thoroughly start sweating that down
we haven't even got a corn in there yet
and already it's looking
and smelling incredible
add salt but remember you've got bacon
in there which is salty so proceed with
caution
really important to sweat those potatoes
off i love getting that flavor from the
smoky bacon
in with the potatoes
now once the leek is sweated off
creamed corn
a popular side dish in the states
creamed corn is made from fresh frozen
or even tinned corn cooked with onion
butter and cream and can be bought ready
made that starts to give the foundation
the soup
the creamed corn add the sweet corn
then
your stock
don't flood the soup
just bring the stock to underneath the
ingredients you can always add very
difficult to take away
homemade chicken stock is so cheap to
make just boil up your roast chicken
bones with a few fresh veg and freeze in
batches for when you need it
lighten the load with a touch of milk
that gives a really nice bright color
now bring that up to the ball
turn it down and let it simmer for 12 to
15 minutes
as it cooks slowly the starch thickens
the soup the bacon renders
and that leek
onion starts to puree and the corn just
shines
okay next we're gonna make the american
cheese biscuits in the uk they're known
as scones but in america they're called
biscuits
[Music]
first put plain flour into a sieve
add baking powder and sift both into a
bowl
next add some salt
pepper and grated mature cheddar cheese
mix the dry ingredients then make it
well in the center
pour in double cream and gently combine
with a wooden spoon
turn your dough out onto a floured
surface and knead for a few seconds only
if you overwork it your cheese biscuits
won't rise
roll out your dough to about two
centimeter thick and cut into four
centimeter round biscuits
[Applause]
place well apart on a lined baking sheet
and leave to rest on the tray for about
10 minutes
then brush the top of each biscuit with
melted butter and bake for about 30
minutes at 160 degrees c in a preheated
oven
when your cheese biscuits are well risen
and a beautiful golden brown remove
deliciously moorish served hot or cold
time to dole out my thrifty lunch
i always like to leave a soup to stand
or rest
it looks richer it gets rid of all the
stock
i like to have two thirds ingredient
one-third of the stock so it looks like
a nice delicious
chunky soup
into the bowl
[Music]
beautiful tin sweet corn a leek potato
and some streaky bacon but it doesn't
look like it's just come out of a store
cupboard that is proper hearty food
[Music]
served with my american style cheese
biscuits this thrifty lunch may have
been made on a shoestring but without an
ounce of compromise on freshness and
flavor
noodle soup with poached egg and spring
onions
[Music]
add miso paste to boiling water
japanese misu has a wonderful deep
savoury richness and is brilliant in
soups
grating fresh ginger
add dry shiitake mushrooms that have
been soaked in water
season with soy sauce
crack an egg add it to the broth and
poach for two to three minutes
add thinly sliced portobello mushrooms
to a serving bowl
put in fresh medium egg noodles which
will heat through in the hot meso broth
add spinach
[Music]
then simply spoon the broth into your
bowl
top with the egg
and fresh chopped spring onions
so simple so good and so delicious ready
in 10 minutes super fast noodle soup
with poached egg and spring onions
my recipe for meatballs is so versatile
it can be used to make a dozen amazing
dishes
one of my favorites is meatballs in
fragrant coconut broth
having a freezer of home-cooked
delicious food ready to go can be a real
life saver it means you never have to
compromise on flavor these meatballs are
delicious but more importantly they
freeze so well
first off get your pan on and start
sweating off your onions and your garlic
this recipe involves making the
meatballs a classic way
but the exciting part
is actually cook them in coconut milk
and it gives a really nice new dimension
to a sort of soft
rich sumptuous meatball
chop the onion nice and finely keeping
those slices very close together closer
the slices the finer the onions
pat it back down at an angle slice down
and just
chop i want the onions nice and fine
because i want some finesse to these
meatballs the secret of a really good
meatball is the texture
getting that balance right
between the minced beef the breadcrumbs
the milk
and the seasoning a couple cloves of
garlic slice the garlic really nice and
thinly
nice pan nice and hot a tablespoon of
olive oil quite generous with the olive
oil
onions and garlic in we'll touch the
salt
and pepper
with your mince open it up a little bit
and sort of pat it out
salt
and
pepper for me
a good meatball is all about the
the softness the texture of that rich
beef
and the way it sort of melts in your
mouth you can color it on the outside
but you want it nice and soft and sort
of rich in the center mix that in
beautifully
and then paste it back out again i've
got some really nice
dried chili flakes i'm gonna season the
onions with the chili flakes chili
flakes in
cook that out for two minutes
i'm gonna add some milk
[Music]
take your bread crumbs make a little
well three four tablespoons of milk that
makes a sort of nice
slightly doughy texture
but it lightens the texture of the
meatball
place that
in
add your onions your garlic and your
chilli in there as well
nice put your hands in there and start
mixing them
if you've got the right amount of milk
and breadcrumbs doesn't mean binding
with an egg
don't make them too small
the problem with making them too small
is the fact that they dry out quickly
just the size of a golf ball
a little bit bigger
nice
really nice tight squeeze
that stops it from breaking up
it always pays to double the recipe and
spend a bit more time making extra
meatballs so you can freeze a batch
ready for another time give the pan a
little wipe out
don't wash out that pan we've got that
flavour from the onions and the garlic
at the bottom get that pan nice and hot
a touch of olive oil in there
place them
at the top of your pan
nice and gently
sit them in the oil
get a pallet knife and go underneath
them and just sort of
tilt the pan and let the pan cook the
back of the meatball we're going to add
some heat coanda seeds slightly spicy
and peppery just to give a really nice
flavor to the coconut milk in
next some cardamom seeds three or four
onto the board knife on
in a little touch of turmeric into the
center of the pan that's going to give
it a really nice spicy flavor
a little pinch
of cinnamon
all the time you're doing this those
meatballs are just getting tastier and
tastier a couple of dried chilies let
them infuse in that oil
and then some lemongrass just take the
back of your knife and sort of
beat it down that starts to release all
that lovely sort of fragrance like
someone's just
let off the most amazing
fragrant air freshener in the lemongrass
and finally some fresh ginger
just peel
and slice nice and thinly
time now
to turn them over
and let the other half a wonderful
flavor
chicken stock
in
bring the stock up to the boil turn the
gas up and then add the coconut milk
i want the coconut milk just sitting
underneath the top of the meatball
coconut milk in
and that sort of
gives it that creamy richness but it's
not heavy it's a fragrant
light richness
before we start simmering check the
seasoning
that nice soft texture of the meatball
but that fragrance light richness of the
coconut broth just gonna cook those
meatballs perfectly
bring the broth up to the boil
then simmer gently for eight to ten
minutes
touch them with your finger this should
be slightly pliable but
slightly springy gas off i'm going to
finish it off with something light and
fresh zest of lime but i want the zest
on top of the meatball
so cut through that richness and then
finally
squeeze the fresh lime
and that just gives it that nice
zesty amazing taste
stir in the juice
mmm
i've got that kick and that
vibrant taste
now
the exciting part
when you come to serve it
be generous with that coconut broth
tilt the pan
get a good couple of ladles of the broth
in
meatballs
[Music]
and that is a very
delicious way of eating a old-fashioned
meatball
and bringing it into the 21st century
and they're just as good cooked from
frozen as well
[Music]
you